[Musique]
la chaleur intense euh lorsque vous vous rapprochez,
je pensais que j'allais pouvoir me rapprocher beaucoup,
vous ne pouvez pas vous approcher de plus de quatre
mètres environ, même si le truc noir
parce que  il fait euh si chaud et puis le
son de la lave en éruption et les
éclaboussures dramatiques
c'est très très excitant j'ai
attendu des années et des années pour voir de la lave c'est
un objectif de vie et quand je suis venu sur cette
colline
et nous avons décidé nous allons  descendons
et nous allons nous rapprocher et c'est un
risque et nous le savons mais nous allons le
faire
nous faisons du trekking ici et j'étais comme si
je devais arrêter bébé arrête
je devais m'asseoir et j'avais  pleurer un
peu parce que c'est si beau et
si émouvant et c'est comme notre
puissance brute de notre planète
[Musique]
toi